hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar current and future directions of
the nih brain initiative
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
john guy director of the nih's brain
research through advancing innovative
neurotechnologies or brain initiative
and dr mohamed gesemi assistant
professor of computer science and
engineering at michigan state university
dr ngai and dr gasemi you may now begin
your presentation
hi uh first of all i'd like to thank the
organizers for this invitation to tell
you a bit about the brain initiative
and
our current and future directions which
hopefully will serve as a nice
introduction and backdrop for the rest
of today's exciting talks
so the uh mission of the brain research
through advancing innovative
neurotechnologies or brain initiative is
to revolutionize our understanding of
the human brain by accelerating the
development and application of
innovative technologies
uh this initiative was announced by the
white house in 2013 with the first
awards in 2014
and represents a partnership between
five u.s federal agencies as well as
private foundations
now the nih efforts have been guided by
two strategic plans the so-called brain
2025 report that was issued in 2014
as well as a revisit of the strategic
plan in 2019 as issued in the brain 2.0
reports
now the goal of the nih brain initiative
is to develop and apply new tools for
understanding how neural circuits
underlie complex behaviors in both
health and disease arguably
the central theme of today's symposium
to do so we need to leverage the
technological innovations to enable new
discoveries about neural circuit
function
to use these discoveries as a foundation
for new therapeutic strategies for human
brain disorders and very importantly to
disseminate and democratize technologies
for basic discovery and clinical
applications
now i mentioned the brain 2.0 reports uh
this
revisit of the strategic plan and i just
wanted to summarize for you
some major points that were brought up
in both the brain 2.0 neuroscience
report as well as the neuroethics report
the first was to stay on the productive
path that was already underway for the
brain initiative in other words keep on
doing what's working well to continue
supporting technology development and
targeted study of circuit components
which you'll hear a lot about today
the second was to balance individual
investigator research with team science
there's clearly a place for both
um
the uh the beauty and i think success of
nih-funded research is that we ask
investigators to come in with their best
ideas and to pursue exciting hypothesis
driven research at the same time there
are some projects which we'll talk a bit
about today that really do require a
team approach some of it hypothesis
driven but some of some of it driven
toward building tools that allow us to
ask and answer better and more precise
questions
the third point i'd like to emphasize
here is the importance of enhancing the
integration of neuroscience and
neuroethics this question of what are
the impacts of our work how will that
impact uh broader uh
issues in society and not to consider
these just the tail end of our studies
but really to bake it in from the very
beginning so we really do understand
what we're getting into and that we can
navigate uh space which at some time at
some points can be quite fraught
especially as it involves the human
brain and human behaviors
and then finally the last point
that i'd like to emphasize here
is this
suggestion to devote ample resources
towards scaling up large projects that
could transform the way we conduct
neuroscience research for generations to
come now you can also get more details
about this plan at the link that i show
here at the bottom of the slide
so i'd like to spend a little bit of
time here today
to describe to you these so-called brain
2.0 transformative projects that we are
embarking on for the next phase of the
brain initiative the next five plus
years and hopefully you can see how this
will impact the work that's going going
to be discussed today
and beyond and then i'll tie it in with
the subject of today's talks
so we chose to pursue three large
projects these so-called transformative
projects that we do believe will
transform the way we conduct
neuroscience research in the future
uh the first is the phase three of the
brain cell census project
um this is to build a uh literally a
parts list of the brain uh right now we
are in phase two the so-called brain
initiative cell census network or biccn
where the focus has mainly been on the
mouse brain but with some work on
non-human primate in human brains and
for phase three we will be moving the
emphasis uh primarily but not
exclusively to uh generate comprehensive
cell atlases of human brains
now a series of rfas were just released
they're shown right here with receipt
dates coming in november 2021
so let me just give you uh in turn a bit
of
background for each of these three
transformative projects starting here
with this brain initiative cell atlas
network and i'll move on to the other
ones as we go along i should also
mention that congress has allocated to
us specific funds to allow us to launch
this transformative project starting in
next year
so the idea and motivation behind the
cell census work is that we need a parts
list and a wiring diagram for the brain
and a way to interrogate and modulate
brain circuits so the three projects
i'll tell you about today touch on each
of these three areas the parts list the
wiring diagram and a way to interrogate
and modulate
so in order to understand how this
marvelous biological biological computer
works we really need to understand what
are its components how many do we have
of each what are their properties and
very importantly how do they communicate
with each other how do they wire in with
each other
now this has been a central a century a
century old problem dating back to the
days of romani kahal
uh but we what we need right now is a
systematic way to identify and classify
and characterize these hundreds if not
thousands of different cell types that
comprise the mammalian brain
so this effort uh started uh back in
2014 in a pilot phase of the cell census
project which was referred to as the
brain initiative cell census consortium
uh and the idea behind the the brain
initiative cell
census consortium or biccc
was to identify and validate scalable
technologies that could be deployed
to uh result in a comprehensive brain
cell atlas based on multiple the
multiple properties exhibited by
individual cell types so i was fortunate
to be a pi in that effort uh way back in
2014 and then the next phase of this
project was this the brain initiative
cell census network which was a scale up
of the effort
based on the lessons learned in in those
pilot studies
and so the the goal of the brain
initiative cell census network of biccn
was to revolutionize the ability to
classify brain cell types based on an
integrated analysis of their molecular
anatomical and physiological properties
and this was a bold ambition but i think
we have
made quite a bit of progress here
so let me just describe to you what the
bicc on our brain initiative cell census
network is and
in terms of organization and and
hopefully you can see how this will
provide a foundation for the much more
challenging uh endeavor of scaling this
uh
this project to characterizing cell
types in the human brain
so the biccn is a multi-project
consortium or network
it's centered around three large u19
production projects shown here at the
top of the slide focused again on the
mouse
on the mouse brain together with a
series of smaller but quite substantial
ul1 projects
aimed mainly at
identifying connectivity properties
among those cell types that are
identified to the right in red are a
series of u1 projects that are focused
on characterizing cell types in human
and non-human primate brains and on the
left are a series of r01 type projects
aimed at developing improved scalable
tools and assays to accelerate the
entire endeavor
and actually this slide is a bit out of
date there are more projects ongoing
that are listed right here
now the efforts among the biccn are
coordinated through this
brain cell
data coordination center bcdc which
coordinates not only the efforts among
the entire network but also helps
organize the data coming out of this
network into a series of data archives
shown on the toward the bottom in light
blue as well as
data integration and analysis uh
projects that are related to that all
using data standards that are currently
under development now the ultimate goal
here is to disseminate
this information out to the general
the general scientific community
shown here schematically toward the
bottom
so very importantly is this this uh this
um
this
structure to coordinate the activities
and here you can see in the middle of
the slide the brain cell data center or
bcdc that coordinates and directs
traffic to make sure that the data are
winding up in the
brain data archives here the three main
data archives for the biccn are the nemo
archive for transcriptomic and
epigenomic information
the brain imaging library for microscopy
imaging information and the more
recently stood up dandy archive for
neurophysiology data and on the right
we're in the process of developing
tools that can be used by other users
outside this group to both mine and
analyze and interpret the information
that's held in these archives
so very very important component is how
we get the data out there and make it
accessible for all to use
so just as an example of of where this
uh study has gotten to so far
as a test case to see
whether this network could actually work
collaboratively and effectively
to uh generate a multimodal atlas in
other words an atlas of cell types based
on multiple modalities
there was a decision made early on to
focus on one part of the cortex in this
case the primary motor cortex
in mouse
marmosets and humans
using a variety of approaches which are
shown here on this on the second level
of this diagram various uh iterations of
single cell or single single nucleus rna
sequencing or transcriptomics a single
nucleus methyl c uh sequencing
single nucleus atexi to identify uh
regions of open chromatin
to give us a comprehensive outlook of
what cell types might look like based on
the molecular information
murphish or
high throughput in situ hybridizations
to gain spatial information about
molecularly identified cells
a technique known as patch seek which
now allows us to
gain information on single cells not
only about their transcriptomics but
also about their morphology location as
well as physiology so truly integrating
across multiple modalities
uh ways of tying in uh all this
molecular information with the
connectivity patterns of these cells and
a technique that was been named epi
retroseq as well as other single cell
morphology techniques to uh to again
characterize the long-range conductivity
patterns of the molecularly identified
cell types so this has resulted in a
multimodal analysis of cell types in the
primary motor cortex across
mouse marmosets and humans
and what we've gained here
are the organizational principles
underlying the diversification of brain
cell types here using as an example the
primary motor cortex
and we see as for many take-home lessons
one i'd like to highlight here is the
remarkable conservation of cell types
between mouse marmoset and humans and
this really does set the stage for
scaling up the entire endeavor to
generate a comprehensive brain cell
atlas from humans
now this is really a great example i
think of the power of team science
there were over 250 researchers involved
in this endeavor
with 89 affiliations spanning over 45
institutions hailing from three
different continents so this was a great
team effort a highly collaborative
effort there was as much
knowledge gained about science as there
was about the sociology of science here
and we are really quite excited to see
this uh these advances both in the
science as well as how we do science
toward this much larger scale project
where we will be attacking the entire
human brain as a resource not only for
understanding how the human brain works
but also as a resource for devising
future human therapies for circuit
disorders
so the next project i'd like to tell you
about is the uh so-called armamentarium
project here is a project to organize
resources for brain cell type access and
manipulation across multiple species so
the goal here is to gain exp initially
gain experimental access to brain cell
types
in species that may not have uh
such ease of genetic access through the
germline so in non-human primate brains
and human cells and tissue
many of these tools will involve viral
vector technologies but also there are
non-viral vector technologies um uh in
development as well
the long-term goal here uh in addition
to uh generating better tools for
interrogating and modulating neural
circuits one of the goals that i listed
a few slides ago is to develop new
therapeutic strategies for human brain
disorders using the latest developments
in human in gene therapies and this is a
ways off but we really do need to start
by
having ways of accessing these cell
types somatically
now we have already issued
an rfa for this we've already had one
round of applications come in with a
second receipt date coming later this
fall
and we also have an another rfa the
second one listed here for um
for standing up production uh facilities
in
in partnership with uh these uh
initial uh
technology development projects
so let me just lay out for you a bit of
a groundwork of of why we think this is
an exciting way to go
and again this is another project that
we for which we receive congressionally
directed funds to jump start the effort
in this and actually this fiscal year
so the goal here is to develop new
technologies for cell type access
somatically
one
approach for this is to identify
enhancers that will direct cell type
specific expression
in adeno-associated virus vectors and
here's just a highlight of a recent
publication from basilica tasik and her
colleagues at the allen institute where
they use single cell ataxi to identify
conserved regions of accessible
chromatin associated with specific cell
types in the mouse brain
and then they screen these sequences for
enhancer activity to drive reported gene
expression in specific brain cell types
as delivered through recombinant
adeno-associated virus vectors
and they showed that by using a
combination of a combinatorial approach
where they can mix and match different
vectors with different specificities as
driven by these enhancers they can
provide a very flexible and facile
access to brain cell types that
complement germline methods now this was
initially developed using the mouse as a
model but in associated studies from
jonathan ting's group also the al
institute they could show that some of
these enhancers were also active in
non-human private brains as well as in
human
brain tissues so i hope you can see that
there is a path
not only toward generating better
reagents for accessing cell types and
experimental models but now also a path
toward
thinking about how we might leverage
this information to access cell types in
humans for the purposes of gene therapy
so this is where we are today and we're
really excited to expand this effort to
develop a greater and more extensive
toolkit for brain cell access
so the third project i want to tell you
about is in a more formative stage this
is the whole brain micro connectivity
analysis of the so-called wiring diagram
and the goal here is to develop a
connectivity map of an entire mammalian
brain and hopefully brains at multiple
scales from the macro to the meso to the
micro or nano scale
the brain initiative together with the
department of energy office of science
recently hosted a five workshop series
looking at the state of the art and the
challenges and the opportunities for
what it would take to prosecute such an
effort we've recently published a works
a workshop series report that's
available online at the following doi
you can also find this at the brain
website
so let me just lay out for you in a few
slides what the challenges of of
stepping up such a project really might
be
so here is a um
a summary of a study that was performed
uh by jeff lichtman's lab back in 2015
quite a while ago
where they used automated serial
sectioning of mouse cortex combined with
scanning electron microscopy and a lot
of very intensive
um
statistical analysis for 3d
reconstruction
to reconstruct
the cells and the connections within a
roughly one and a half millimeter cubed
volume
of the mouse cortex
so the entire mouse brain is about uh
500 to 1000 times larger than this one
one and a half millimeter cube uh piece
of cortex that liekman and colleagues
reconstructed so the challenge is how to
scale this up to an entire mammalian
brain
at synapse level resolution is that even
possible today
now the experimental challenge is
collecting data from a whole brain
this will require some
way of sectioning the brain losslessly
in other words to section it but not
lose all the bits in between and
ultimately being able to put them all
back together again
accurately
and we want to be able to bridge scales
again from
from the macro scale
to understand what connects uh different
brain regions to each other to the meso
down to the micro scale where we want to
understand what are the synaptic
connections being made locally so this
is a big challenge
it's also a huge data science challenge
uh to conduct the segmentation
reconstruction and proofreading of such
data sets
one whole mouse brain at nanometer
resolution would is estimated to to
occupy
one exabyte of data that's a humongous
data set a human brain which is another
thousand times larger again would occupy
one zettabyte
which uh if you go on wikipedia it will
tell you a zettabyte is roughly the
annual internet traffic around the
entire world so this is a huge
computational problem
but while we try while we're pondering
the uh the computational problems the
theoretical problems of trying to put
these maps together
experimentally how do we bridge across
these different scales and i think one
way to approach this is to use
multiplicity of modalities
so here's a
high-level summary of an a recent paper
from bobby kasturi's group who can who
showed that they could bridge five
orders of magnitude of scale by using um
diffusion tensor imaging
uh micro micro ct or x-ray tomography
down to em
em uh microscopy
to go from the macro scale down to the
nano scale
where they use this x-ray tomography or
micro ct at one nanometer resolution to
bridge across these different scales so
on the left here i'm showing the um
diffuse intention diffusion tensor
imaging
in the middle we show micro ct which at
one micron resolution is able to
identify and follow and trace individual
axons and then in the upper right are
the is the is an em micrograph showing
the fine structure
of these uh embedded
ultrastructural elements
so we can go from 50 microns dti down to
nanometer
by em bridging it with micro ct at one
micron resolution
and micro micro ct identifies cellular
features and traces and as well as
traces individual myelin and axons as
shown in these figures here and quite
nicely
one couldn't perform the uh
the imaging using all these three
modalities on the same sample so one can
start with dti step down to micro ct and
then ultimately to em and you can see
here on the left is a micro ct image
with a corresponding em image on the
right so there really is a great promise
for bridging these scales by using a
multiplicity modalities and analyzing
hopefully on the same sample to piece
all this information together
and the
advantage of micro ct is that it's
scalable one can scan an entire mouse
brain in seven hours and which results
in about 10 terabytes of data
okay
so these are the three transformative
projects
and what i would argue is that together
they will provide for us the ground
truth to be able to really understand
how circuits underlie behavior and
overall the discoveries and tools being
supported by the brain initiative are
enabling new opportunities for
unraveling the circuits and computations
underlying behavior
this will allow us to identify the cells
and circuits that are involved
and again provide the ground truth for
informing and constraining testable
models for how neural circuits drive
behavior
and i want to stress the importance of
theory in informing experiment and
conversely the importance of experiment
and forming theory which underscores the
critical role of collaboration between
experimentalists and theorists if we
really are truly to understand how these
neural circuits underlie behavior
and the long-term goal of the brain
initiative is to illuminate general
principles that can be applied across
the domain of the different behaviors
that are supported by the
by the brain
so just to uh
kind of come back and and and think
about
the topic of today's symposium
uh i want to just briefly summarize
two programs in the brain initiative
that are aimed at understanding neural
circuit function using the new tools
that are being developed by the brain
initiative as well as in adjacent fields
and so the first program i'll highlight
for you here is this
team research-based brain circuits
program or team bcp
and the motivation here is based on the
one of the recommendations from the
brain 2025 report our strategic plan
that was issued in 2014
and the idea here is that rigorous
theory modeling statistics are advancing
our understanding of complex non-linear
brain functions
where human intuition fails so in other
words we need
a strong theoretical basis for asking
good questions for framing our
experiments and for testing our for
testing those experiments again as a
two-way uh iterative process of
experiment validating theory and theory
and forming experiment
now in order to
have a full integration of theory and
experiment
the purpose here of these large
team-based projects
is to incorporate multiple components
that have teams with diverse research
research expertise spanning uh both
multiple experimental disciplines as
well as
theoretical disciplines uh they can
contain up to five synergistic
synergistic research projects and five
research cores and again the theory
model driven approach is central to the
all of these projects that are funded
through the u19 mechanism
and here's just a high level summary of
the u19 projects that are currently
underway uh that are
investigating various aspects of circuit
function underlying behavior uh from
behavior to cognition and memory to
perception
and you can also see some pretty clever
uh acronyms for these projects and
you'll learn uh i think a bit more about
these projects and in the hours to come
so these are these are the large
team-based uh brain circuit program
program projects
we also have
an r01 a series of r01s
in the so-called theories models and
methods portfolio or tmm portfolio so
again the idea here is to emphasize the
importance of theory and driving the
experimentation and also the
experimentation being a check on the
theory
and literally the goal here is to
develop better theories
better models and better methods for
analyzing uh this complex data space for
the ultimate understanding of the
principles that are underlying neural
circuit function
so with that i'm going to hand it over
to our next speaker but before i do that
i need to acknowledge all the great work
that's done by the over 100
nih program staff that are involved in
this effort
and in particular i'd like to call out
one person here muhammad gosemi who was
our next speaker
now muhammad is our nih brain initiative
data scholar uh it's a special uh
program around nih to bring in a data
scholar to look at and to develop a
novel way of
parsing and understanding the data that
we're generating
muhammad is currently an assistant
professor at michigan state university
and he's been with us for the past year
or so as a gator scholar and what
muhammad will tell you about in the next
next uh 15 minutes or so
is this brain works project that he that
he's been working on so brain work
stands for brain initiative workspace to
organize the knowledge space
uh in a nutshell this is to use
data-driven information-based techniques
to mine the literature to mind the
information out there to identify
topic areas that are currently being
supported by brain
and also very importantly to identify
regions of intersection and the idea
here is to uh to discover
in advance what some emerging new areas
of discovery might be based on the work
that's being done out there today so
this is just a very high level overview
in this graph where the nodes represent
research topics supported by brain
and the edges
represent research performed at topic
intersections and you can see here in
these hairball in this one hairball plot
a couple of uh very well represented
nodes for example in magnetic resonance
imaging
in single cell analysis which is at the
core of the brain cell census project i
just mentioned to you of course
optogenetics is a very powerful tool for
understanding uh neural circuit function
neural pathways etc and what we'd like
to do is be able to use this kind and
other sorts of graph analyses to
identify areas of emerging intersections
and ones that might help us predict
where the next big discoveries might
come from so that's just a very high
level overview i'll let muhammad
describe to you the project in much more
detail
and hand it over to him so over to
yamaha hi i'm mohammad kasimi and i'm an
assistant professor of computer science
at michigan state university and this
year it's been my pleasure and
opportunity to serve at the data and
technology advancement national service
scholar
at the nih
and my presentation today is going to be
taking you through brainworks
now brainworks
at its simplest is a
platform with an ambition of converting
scientific papers
into a knowledge graph
the
overall ambition or motivation for this
really contains two pieces
the first is if you think about
scientific disciplines like neuroscience
it's actually composed of many smaller
subdisciplines
so if you look on the left hand side of
the screen there you can see we've got
social genetic
cellular physiological neurological and
behavioral
subdomains of research all of which
together comprise
the domain of neuroscience
and what scientists in these areas are
doing is they're taking uh grants
usually from the government
and
they're doing excellent work and the
consequence of that
that work is
captured within scientific manuscripts
or papers
and our ambition here is to take those
collections of papers across those
varieties of subdomains
and to create a knowledge graph that
captures
all of the major findings embedded
within those papers and across those
papers
now you might naturally wonder well why
should we do something like this aren't
the papers already there can't we just
read them
and the short answer is yeah absolutely
you certainly could read them but the
scientific domain has especially over
the last
20 years or so
grown increasingly complex and the
volume of scientific output has
really been on a pretty steep growth
curve
on the right hand side of the screen
there what i have is the number of
neuroscience related articles
uh that's the y-axis and along the
x-axis i've got the year
and so there's two points i want to draw
your attention to in that graph
if you kind of scroll your eyes to where
that first arrow is
you can see that what that signifies is
if you wanted to kind of keep up with
the literature
around
1980 you'd have to be reading something
on the order of 13 papers a day and
while that's a that's a lot i mean you
could argue that you could maybe you
could if you're really a prodigious
reader you could consume all of those
but if you fast forward to today
you have to read something on the order
of 70 papers per day if you wanted to
just keep up with what's happening in
the scientific community
and it doesn't look like that curve is
going to be heading down or flattening
out anytime soon so
the thought is that
a tool like frameworks
by turning the scientific papers into a
knowledge graph
might allow us to better digest what's
happening within these domains of
science
and choose research directions a little
bit more strategically and and learn
things that otherwise would have been
challenging to observe
now as i mentioned at the start of the
presentation uh
i'm here at the national institutes of
health
as an as a
a data
and technology advancements national
service scholar and my appointment here
has been
uh ongoing for about
eight months now and we'll be continuing
until the end of the year
the project or delivery of this
frameworks platform has happened in five
phases and i'd like to very quickly
highlight what we've already done
and also where we're going in the next
few minutes
so the first thing that we did was
we
had a series of conversations
at the very early days of this project
with experts inside and outside
the nih
several of those experts inside and
outside
are folks who
you will hear from today or
have heard from probably in other
domains i wanted to just
put all those individuals and their
smiling faces here at the beginning to
acknowledge that they were extremely
helpful in helping us craft that vision
that i articulated in the first couple
of slides for this platform
so once we had
completed
that specification of what we wanted the
brainworks platform to do we then moved
to the next very important stage of this
which was
gathering the data that's going to allow
us to build that platform
and
ultimately what we came up with in that
three or four months intensive data
collection period
was is illustrated here on the slide in
front of you starting from the left we
collected information on about 2.7
million
funded nih projects from 1980 to 2020
that collectively account for something
on the order of half a trillion dollars
in investments in scientific communities
and that half a trillion dollars in
investment went to something on the
order of 5 million scientists
embedded at 100 000 institutions
and those 5 million scientists over the
period authored something on the order
of 3.7 million papers
and those papers cited an additional 6
million papers or so to lead us to a
total collection of around 10 million or
9.5 million papers in our collection
now what we did is once we had
identified
all the projects
all of the scientists were involved in
those projects and all the papers that
those scientists had created and we had
added those to our archive we added two
other pieces of information
first that we did was
we assigned topics to each of the papers
so we can take a paper that's published
by some scientists that were funded by
nih and know for example that it was
about neuroplasticity or know that it
was about magnetic resonance imaging or
a set of other topics
we also collected any sort of patents
that were authored
that were influenced or supported in
part by the funds from nih
now with that data collected what we've
been spending the last couple of months
doing
is generating
tools to analyze and visualize this data
set that we have collected
and i'd like to
take you through in the next
10 minutes or so
what some of those preliminary analytic
techniques and visualizations of the
data look like and just note here up
front that
this tool is still evolving so
uh there'll
certainly be more work to come on what
i'm about to show you
so at the end of john's presentation he
showed you something that looked a
little bit like this there was
this is a topics graph
and the way that we generated this was
we took all of those papers that exist
within that 10 million or so paper
collection that we spoke about and we
said hey which subset of those papers
were funded by
uh the brain initiative in from 2014 all
the way up to 2020.
and then let's do two things with that
with those papers let's identify what
the topics are and for each of the
topics let's go ahead and put a node
on this graph that you see in front of
you
and then every time we see
within a given
paper two topics that occur let's draw
an edge between
uh those two topics that we see on this
map here
and so the general structure that you
see in front of you for this topic map
communicates those two pieces of
information what are the sets of topics
that showed up
as well as what are the co-occurrences
between the topics as communicated by
the nodes and the edges respectively
now there's a couple of other pieces of
information that this topic graph
highlights for us the the first is we've
sort of made the text hovering above the
notes larger if that topic was more
represented or showed up
in in the papers more so you can see
magnetic resonance imaging as an example
is a large piece of text single cell
analysis optogenetics and so on
and then if we want to look at an
example a little closer to the top of
the graph we can see that there are
connections between
neural pathways and movement
and so there was there were studies that
have been funded by the brain initiative
at those interfaces now what this graph
really does is it provides a wonderful
overview of the impact that
the nih has had on
a very wide variety of disciplines and
i'm not even showing the whole piece of
it here we sort of simplified it for the
sake of creating a visual
and what i'd like to do is to highlight
what frameworks tool is capable of in
addition to just building a topic graph
i'd like to zoom in on one of the topics
in
this graph specifically the
neuroplasticity topic that you see right
there
and if we take that and we kind of open
it up
we are we might be interested in seeing
of the papers that were published on
neuroplasticity
what are some of the other topics that
co-occurred
with
uh those neuroplasticity papers because
the co-occurrence of the topics could
tell us things about
trends in in research
so for example one of the simplest
analysis we could do is we could
take along the xx here the year
again 1980 to 2020 we could put along
the y-axis the number of papers that
exist in our archive and we could split
that number of papers
according to some of the topical
qualities of these neuroplasticity
papers such as whether they used humans
or animals in the course of study what
you'd see here if you take your eyes and
look from the left all the way to the
right is that
animal studies were predominantly what
were done for neuroplasticity research
in earlier times but as time has gone on
we've seen
more work with humans in this domain and
we have
taken the topics that we've uh imprinted
upon
these neuroscience papers and we've
hierarchically organized them and what
that allows us to do is say if we want
to drill into
a particular topic and kind of explode
it out we have a capability to do that
let's do that for instance with the the
animals topic represented by the orange
bars here we can take that animal's
topic and
spread it out into
various animals that sort of comprise
that that topic
so now what we have is the same plot
that we showed in the last slide
but
in addition to the humans in blue
instead of just having animals we have
the particular kind of animal that was
used in neuroplasticity research at
various points in time
and here what we see is that a slightly
more nuanced story that
yes while animals were used
earlier and you know humans have been
used a lot more in later times
uh
the community switched from using
rats more to using mice more in the
course of experiments in neuroplasticity
now these kinds of conclusions
um are things that maybe a person who's
not an expert at
neuroplasticity or neuroplasticity
research it would take quite a lot of
reading through papers to conclude
something like this and the goal of a
tool like frameworks is to allow for the
exploration of these sorts of
associations
so that more informed research uh
decisions can get made
so if we come back now for a minute to
this plot
it's
i want you to imagine that the ambition
of our tool is that for any topic that
you see here and any topical interface
that you see here
you could zoom in get an idea of how
things are changing over time uh not
only at the level of topics but
in the future at the level of the
natural language text and its properties
as well
but of course
a topic graph or any kind of research
output graph which is what this
represents isn't
something that just exists it's
it's created by
excellent researchers the kind of
researchers that you will be hearing
from in some of the sessions later today
these are world leaders in their domains
and there might be a question of how do
the interactions or collaborations
between researchers in those domains
impact the output of science and the
kinds of things that we end up
discovering
and brainworks also provides a way for
us to understand the role of those
authors in the creation of science
so for example we might
we might be interested in
how collaborative projects impact author
networks as well as their papers and we
might we might have an interest in using
frameworks to answer a question like
that
and so
one thing that i did
uh because we were interested in this
was to take a population of around 1 500
researchers that were affiliated with 60
or so
scientific labs
and to split them into an intervention
and a control group so 30 of those labs
had received an award from the nih to
help foster
additional collaborative efforts across
labs and then 30 of those labs the other
half
had received that same award but at a
later point in time they got it 2019 or
after
so what we did was we said okay let's
take these two groups who we know are
probably similar in terms of their
credentials because they receive the
same collaborative uh award at some
point
let's look at their activities two years
before 2017. that's when the first the
intervention group got it and two years
after which is you know we can we want
to contrast what the output of the two
groups were in these time periods to see
what the impact of this collaborative
award was on output
and
what i'm showing you here in this plot
is a network visualization
that helps us understand some of the
nuances of the answer
what i'd like to do for a minute is
explain first how to interpret the nodes
in the edges and then we're going to
talk a little more formally about what
we concluded from the analysis
so what we have here like any network
plot our nodes and edges the nodes here
correspond to individual authors
sides of the node indicates how much of
an increase in
the author's output there was over the
four year period
and the color of the node indicates
membership in a lab so for example you
can see there's clusters of orange nodes
of green nodes and blue nodes that's
because
those people all work together in a
scientific laboratory
you might also notice that there are
edges and the way to interpret those
edges is that if there's any edge
between authors it means that over that
four year period we were studying there
was an increase in collaboration
you might notice that some of those
edges are orange which means that
there were collaborations across groups
different colored nodes and then some of
the edges are blue which means that they
were collaborations that increased
within the group
okay so what i'm showing you here in
this network is
for that control group the group that
didn't receive the award in the period
that we were thinking about but received
it later this is how their collaborative
network structure looks like
and what you can see here if you kind of
just highlight a couple things is that
there are
several sort of islands that exist that
have highlighted where there was
increased collaboration within the group
but then there were also some
locations here where there were more
collaborations between the groups
at the top we see there's a small
collaboration between three authors from
three labs
there's a major collaboration between
two groups as indicated by that cluster
of green and blue uh interacting
and then there is a little more minor
collaboration between two groups that
i'm showing there at the bottom and this
visualization allows us to sort of see
the data at a level of nuance like that
everything i showed you before
was in a kind of control group that was
the group who didn't receive the award
if we take and do that exact same
analysis
looking at changes in the output for
these
authors over the time period and changes
in their collaborative relationships
over the time period what we see here is
a graph that has some things in common
but then some important differences and
what i'd like to do is highlight first
those differences
you can see here that
in these two locations i've highlighted
there are these big kind of messy super
clusters i'm going to call them with
many different colors and it's sort of a
jumbled up mess
and now while that may not look as
pretty to your eye or to my eyes it's
actually a really wonderful thing uh
from a scientific collaboration
perspective because it means these
authors were
working together so closely that when we
tried to sort of take this network and
and
get people
who were in clusters to be sort of as
separate from each other as we could we
couldn't easily detangle that group when
we were constructing the graph
that bodes extremely well for what the
impact of the collaborative award was in
this case and this is really meant to
highlight
um
that a tool that we're building allows
us to do these kinds of investigations
and to see
nuance in the data that may not have
been easy to do otherwise
so that sort of covers a quick overview
of what we've done with the tool today
and our next steps
what i will be working on between now
and the end of the year
is the development of a user interface
so that instead of
seeing data like this in a presentation
you might be able to click through a
website and play with some of these
graphics yourself do explorations on
your own and see what you come up with
uh specifically i'll be working on
search functionality graph
representation and group comparisons
within the online tool over the coming
months
and so with that i would like to thank
you for your attention
i'd like to really encourage you to
attend and enjoy
the excellent
scientists that we'll be presenting
later today and also
offer for you to reach out and contact
me if you have interest in brainworks or
ideas for what we might be able to do
with the tool thanks